So, I talked about idolatry being very
broad. Do you want me to expand on what
idolatry is? Because some people think
idolatry means just worshipping false
gods and goddesses, right? Yeah, go
ahead. I want you to understand what
idolatry is. It's It's very broad.
In a nutshell, idolatry is anything
other than God
that you live for. So, that can be false
gods, but it can also be your own
desires. For example,
living for money,
living for your position, living for
your job, living for your children. Even
your children and your spouse can be an
idol. Whatever you live for, whatever
consumes your time and energy, whatever
becomes the focus where you're willing
to sacrifice everything else for, that
becomes your God.
And where am I getting it from? Getting
it from the Bible.
Mhm.
So, you see how broad it is?
Right.
So, that means
your wife can be your idol.
Your children can be your idol.
Your position at work can be your idol.
Your desire to become a millionaire can
be your idol.
Anything that consumes you, and anything
that you're willing to sacrifice
anything else for and everything else
for, that idol becomes your God.
And I'll show it to you from scripture.
See, the Bible has all the answers, but
a lot of people don't like the answers
that they find in the Bible. Well, like
I said, I didn't write this book. Mhm. I
would have written it very differently.
But, nonetheless,
Colossians 3, because I'm a wicked
sinner. Put to death, therefore, your
members which are on the earth. Sexual
immorality. May God help us. Young men,
pray for me. I pray for you. Lord, help
us stay pure. Forgive us. And any woman
in our lives, keep them pure. Forgive
them and strengthen them. Who confess
and acknowledge, not justify.
Uncleanliness, depraved passion, having
unnatural sick passion such as
pedophilia, child You name it. Incest.
Evil desire. Now, watch what idolatry
is. Covetousness, which is idolatry.
Do you see he just called coveting
idolatry?
Why? Because when you covet something,
your
desire
to have the thing you covet
may lead you to become so obsessed with
it that now everything you do
revolves around getting a hold of the
thing that you covet. So, it becomes
your God.
Mhm. So, you're willing to sacrifice
your wife and children. You're willing
to sacrifice church. You're willing to
sacrifice your friends
and spend all that time and energy
trying to get a hold of the thing that
you covet passionately.
For example, if you are coveting to
become rich
and are willing to sacrifice going to
church with the family, or are willing
to sacrifice spending more time at home
with your kids who need you. Because
your kids don't care that you're working
12 hours cuz you think by making more
money, you can be a better provider and
get them the things they need. When
children need the love and attention of
a parent.
Right. But, in your sick mind, you're
thinking, "No, no, no, I'm doing them a
favor. I'm going to be at home at work
from 6:00 a.m. till 10:00 p.m. They
won't see me. I won't have dinner with
them, leaving my wife with the children
all No, that's not being a good dad.
That's being a
covetous idolater.
Where you sacrifice your family, and
then you wonder why your kids grown up
grow up to be broken
with severe psychological issues, drug
addiction, end up in jail. In fact,
statistics show
fatherless boys
have a higher chance
of
ending up in jail because they didn't
have a father figure in their life.
Statistics confirm the truth of the
Bible.
Mhm. This is why covetousness is
idolatry. Again, he says it here.
Ephesians 5:5.
Know this for sure that no sexually
immoral person, nor unclean person, nor
covetous man, who is an idolater,
has any inheritance in the kingdom of
Christ and God. So, whatever you live
for,
whatever becomes the very focus of your
life, so that your day begins and ends
focusing on that very thing,
and you're willing to sacrifice
everything else for that thing, that
becomes your God. And so, what does Paul
say here? Look what he says. Philippians
3, sorry.
3:16 to 19.
Nevertheless, to the extent that we have
already attained, let's walk by the same
rule. Let's be of the same mind. All
Christians have to be like-minded, agree
on the same things, cuz there's one God
and his truth is one,
and the teaching is one. That's why God
hates denominations.
Mhm. [clears throat]
>> Brothers, be imitators together with me.
And note those who walk this way. See
who acts like me as I act like Christ
and imitate them and me,
even as you have us for an example. For
many walk, of whom I told you often, and
not and now tell you even with weeping
with a broken heart, they walk in
opposition to Christ and are enemies of
the cross of Christ and scorn the
gospel.
Whose end is destruction.
Now, notice what their God is. What is
their God?
Before the rapture?
One second, sorry. I'm belly. I'm trying
to the belly.
Are you pretending to pay attention? No,
sorry. I'm trying to get my phone to
charge. It's about to die.
>> What's the matter, Elizabeth? Elizabeth?
You're on the phone and not on a
computer, Elizabeth. Um is the belly.
This guy has a belly, sorry.
How can your belly be your God? What
does he mean there?
I'm from I would understand today's
world to be like your your like appetite
for certain things.
Your desires and your passions to
gratify your sexual desires. Your desire
for sex, your desire for money, your
desire for pleasure, your desire for
>> [snorts]
>> you know, Gucci watch. You name it. Mhm.
That's what it means your belly. Your
sinful desires. The desires of your
flesh. When you live for your desires,
you make those desires your God. And
then you glory in your shame. Meaning,
you're even
public about it. What does that mean?
Look around you. All these dudes that
are flashing their bling bling, their
jewelry,
their
their cars, the 20 babes that they're
banging. And they glory in that. You
even have music videos where there's
half-naked women and they're treating
them like
and they glory in that. They revel in
that. They boast, "Look at me. Look at
all these hoes." You understand what the
point is?
>> Mhm. Yeah.
Instead of being embarrassed by it,
being ashamed of it, hiding it,
they go about parading it. No shame.
Their shame is their glory. They They
glory in it. "Look, man. Look at all
these women I'm banging, bro. Look at my
Look at my
Mhm. Who think about earthly things.
See, the Bible has the answers for
everything, doesn't it?
Yes. It That seems like it for sure.
Yep. Now, the final thing that can be an
idol.
1 Timothy 6:6-10.
But, godliness with contentment is great
gain. Meaning,
if God blesses you to move higher in
your office and make more money, glory
to God. Aim for that. But, not to the
point where it becomes your obsession.
Be content that your wife and children
have enough clothes and food and a roof
over their table and they're not
starving, they're not hungry, they're
not homeless. Be content.
Because your purpose in life is to be
godly and to make sure your spouse and
children are godly, so they grow up to
be godly and not sinful and add to the
corruption of society.
For we brought nothing into the world.
You didn't bring in any Gucci watches or
Rolexes or or
>> [clears throat]
>> cars or You didn't bring anything. When
you came out of your mother's womb, you
came out You came out naked. And you're
going to return to the dust naked. Mhm.
And we certainly can't carry anything
out. But, having food and clothing, we
will be content with that.
My kids have enough to eat. They got
beds. They got a roof over their head.
They got clothes. My wife is taken care
of. Glory to God. So, what I don't have
a home? So, what I don't have a 2025
brand new car?
As long as my car gets the job done, and
as long as they know they're not
neglected, and as long as my kids
are receiving the attention from mom and
dad, and we're there for them, and not
an absentee dad, that someone else is
raising them besides dad, who's supposed
to be an example of Christ,
that's what matters.
I'll be content with that. Because those
who are determined to be rich fall into
temptation, a snare, and many foolish
and harmful lusts, such as drown men in
ruin and destruction. Meaning, when
you're obsessed to get rich, the
temptation will be such where you're
going to now make compromises and do
things you wouldn't normally do, such as
lying, cheating, conniving, which will
then plunge you in destruction and in
trouble, and maybe jail time, or get
Isn't that true?
Yes.
Why? For the love of money. Notice what
Paul did not say.
He did not say money is evil.
Didn't say that. Your love of money,
your lust of money is what makes money
evil.
Money in of itself is amoral, meaning
money is not a person that can be moral
or immoral. Mhm. Money is neutral. It's
what you do with money that can make it
a means of evil.
So, amoral, not immoral. It's morally
neutral.
A godly man can use money for godly
purposes to advance the kingdom. An
ungodly heathen can use that same money
to sow corruption, spread evil, and sin,
and harm others,
but he doesn't care, she doesn't care as
long as
it makes them more money.
For the love of money is the root of all
kinds of evil.
Just look at P. Diddy. His lust for
money and fame and power, look what he
did to other people, wrecked their
lives, sodomized them, right?
Did it to them.
That's because of the love of money, cuz
the more money you have, the more power
you have, the higher your status. Some
have been led astray from the faith in
their greed, and have pierced themselves
through with many sorrows. Go ask P.
Diddy if he's happy where he ended up.
He might be a little bit. Well, yeah,
not for long when he's got Bubba next
>> [laughter]
>> next to him. But you understand the
whole point. This is what
idolatry is. Idolatry is not just
worshipping other gods
or statues. Idolatry can be more subtle.
It's whatever you live for and are
willing to sacrifice, even if it's your
job, your status, your position, or
living for your wife and children,
putting them ahead of God. That can be
an idol.
Yeah.
So, this is the answer your questions. I
don't know if you have any more. I'm
standing up because my cat always
bothers me, wants to go out, so I got to
open the door. Oh, no, you're all good.